hey remember when the FBI got caught
spying on Catholics whom the agency
referred to as potential violent
extremists that was back in February
when an FBI memo leaked smearing us
mackerel Snappers as terrorists in
waiting and encouraging agents to
infiltrate churches and even go so far
as to get priests to rat on their flocks
it was pretty egregious even by the
standards of the extremely corrupt Biden
justice department so when FBI director
Christopher Wray was grilled on that
memo by Jim Jordan Rey did not even
attempt to defend it
between a traditional catholic and a
radical traditional catholic
I'm not an expert on the Catholic orders
well your FBI wrote a memo talking about
radical traditional Catholics I'm just
wondering if you can Define it for us
well what I can tell you is you're
referring to the Richmond product which
is a single product by a single field
office which as soon as I found out
about it I was aghast and ordered it
withdrawn and removed from FBI systems
you were a guest then why won't you let
us talk to the people who put it
together we are working on finishing an
internal review into what happened we
have to wait we the Congress and the
American people have to wait until you
do an internal review it's not a
criminal investigation going on here an
internal review before we can talk to
the people who wrote this we when we
finish our internal review which will be
very soon we will come come back in
America to provide a briefing on what we
found well we appreciate and we briefing
we want to talk to the people who wrote
it
Jim Jordan's so good he's just he just
knows exactly what the guy is going to
say he's anticipating all of it
Christopher Ray doesn't have much of an
answer other than to say
look it was just one office just one
office okay
that is what the FBI director said just
one Memo from one field office which Ray
rejected the moment he saw it and then
guess what happened next
you guessed it
turns out that Christopher Ray's claim
like so many FBI and doj claims in
recent years was a big fat lie turns out
that that one FBI field office
coordinated with multiple field offices
all across the country
to smear normal practicing Catholics as
domestic terrorists
will Rey be investigated for perjury
himself probably not will Biden be
investigated for wielding the state to
Target and harass his innocent enemies
probably not
but will conservatives recognize the
pattern here
I hope so
because this is a pattern that crops up
throughout all of history
when radical leftists really want to
seize power
they always go after the Catholics
always I know America's not a majority
Catholic country it doesn't matter they
go after the Catholics always the very
term leftist comes from the French
Revolution where the Catholics sat on
the right of the National Assembly and
the people who wanted to behead the
priests and nuns and king and queen sat
on the left who did the Communists
attack with special Vigor in the Spanish
Civil War it was the Catholics
priests nuns as well as ordinary lay
people who do the Bolsheviks attack in
their Revolution there aren't that many
Catholics in Russia so they attacked the
closest thing they attacked the Russian
Orthodox church and they didn't just
incidentally attack them they did so in
the most gruesome of ways Lenin
crucified priests
poured molten lead down their throats in
a mockery of Holy Communion particularly
gruesome specific hideous attacks on the
most traditional Orthodox Christian
people you could find
now you might not be Christian
you might not be Catholic
you might not think
that the persecution of parishes here in
the United States affects you
maybe it doesn't
yet but it will
radical revolutionaries they don't start
out by targeting some Corporation they
don't start out by targeting ordinary
people's homes and businesses
they don't start out by attacking the
gym or the concert hall they always
start with the churches first because
the church has always been their
foremost enemy and obstacle a Michael
noses the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by good ranchers get
great meat at a secure price and 30
bucks off your order with my code
Knowles Canada wlas go to
goodranters.com use code Knowles today
hey big news
we've got potential proof of alien life
we'll get to that we'll get to that in a
second we will get to it first though
I don't want to move on from the
corruption of of the Biden
Administration so quickly we got a new
update
to the Joe and Hunter Biden corruption
spin you remember
I'll just take you on a little Whirlwind
tour of what they've said Joe says I
never knew anything about my son's
business dealings overseas never knew
anything about it never heard about it
and then Hunter accidentally tells a
magazine that he and Joe talked about
his business dealings
so then the story becomes I never talked
about well okay we did talk about it but
I didn't
I didn't really know anything I wasn't
involved it was just in passing then we
found out
Joe Biden actually
got on phone calls with Hunter's corrupt
business partners over 20 times so the
story was okay yeah he knew about it
okay yeah he talked to the the crooks
about it but they only talked about the
weather then we got a letter a
handwritten note that Joe Biden sent to
Devin Archer Hunter's business partner
in this corrupt scheme and the the note
said hey thanks for coming to this lunch
with the president of China today sorry
I couldn't hang out with you too much
but really glad you and Hunter are
working together can't wait to see you
with Hunter again keep hanging out with
Hunter
signed Joe Biden okay so now he knew
about it he was on the phone calls with
the crooks he talked with Hunter about
it he talked with the business partner
about it he encouraged the business now
the update is
he had dinner with these guys
Joe Biden showed up to dinner with these
guys and they weren't just taking 80 000
a month here a hundred thousand dollars
over here it wasn't even just the five
million dollar bribe to Joe and the five
million dollar bribe to Hunter that was
reported on now new bank records show 20
million dollars in foreign payments to
the bidens while Joe was VP we've got
pictures of Joe dining with some of the
oligarchs who paid off Hunter Biden
we've got we've got a Russian
billionaire Elena baccharina who's the
wife of former Moscow mayor uh both
linked to Putin who wired three and a
half million bucks to Hunter and Devin
Archer's shell Corporation Rosemont
Seneca Thornton uh three and a half
million bucks in February 2014 so this
is while Joe is still VP
the the Ukrainian barisma company sent a
million dollars in yearly payments to
Hunter and Devon Archer for their
positions on the board of barisma which
of course they knew nothing about
there's a kazakhstani oil oligarch
Kennedy's Rocky Chev who used his
Singaporean company novotus Holdings to
wire Hunter's shell Corporation
142 300 now that's a weird amount why
would this Kazakh oligarch wire a 142
300 to this totally legitimate
Corporation Called Rosemont Seneca
Holdings why would he do that oh because
that just so happens to be the exact
cost of a sports car that Hunter Biden
bought the day after the wire transfer
landed they're barely even hiding it
he could have at least sent the guy 150
Grand or 140 Grand Hunter's got to cover
the extra two G's no it's the exact
amount for the sports car that Hunter
buys the very next day
we've we've got
we've got major spin mode here from the
White House and from Politico the
liberal establishment here's what how
Politico covers it up they say GOP house
oversight chair James Comer rolled out a
new memo identifying over 20 million
bucks in payments from entities or
individuals in Russia Ukraine and
Kazakhstan to Biden family members but
here's the here's the butt but
the memo doesn't show a direct payment
to Joe Biden
oh you don't say wow great investigative
work there Sherlock wow you're you're
telling me
that's it so then it's over forget about
it move on there's nothing to see here
because
the family that we know makes extensive
use of shell corporations the family
that has bragged in text messages about
how they're never going to find the
money the direct link of the money
because it goes through so many shell
corporations you're telling me that that
family laundered money
that's great someone should spring Al
Capone out of prison
you never saw any direct payments to Al
Capone someone hey how about the heads
of those five families in New York how
about John Gotti this you never saw
there's no direct payment to John Gotti
so there you go there
there's no such thing as money
laundering right
well if only if only we had some
evidence if only we had some evidence
that the money that was going to
Hunter's shell Corporation was somehow
making it to Joe Biden if only we had a
text message from Hunter Biden that said
I love you all this is to his daughter I
love all of you but I don't receive any
respect and that's fine I guess works
for you apparently uh I hope you all can
do what I did and pay for everything for
this entire family for 30 years it's
really hard but don't worry unlike Pop I
won't make you give me half your salary
if only we had if only we had text
message evidence of 10 going to the big
guy well I guess that's what we need to
investigate was it 10 or is it half
the White House communications director
retweeted the Politico article with that
quote there are there was no evidence
the memo doesn't show a direct payment
to Joe Biden it's Kate burner the White
House communications director but it was
such a Preposterous defense against so
much overwhelming evidence that Joe
Biden is a crook on the take who's taken
millions and millions of dollars by
selling American influence overseas just
total outright seven-figure eight-figure
bribes it was so embarrassing that
Politico deleted the tweet that the
White House retweeted so nothing white
has has total egg on its face because
even Politico even this liberal hack
outlet that they were that they were
pointing to is see here's the
exonerating evidence even Politico said
okay you're right that was too much that
spin was too much all right we're out of
here
the corruption is just through the roof
and
at least one Republican is focusing most
of his presidential campaign on that
that would be
Donald Trump who who points out now he
he can't even really campaign he
certainly campaigned as he should
because his calendar is now being taken
up with all of these court dates because
he's being prosecuted by his opponent
how can my corrupt political opponent
crooked Joe Biden put me on trial during
an election campaign that I'm winning by
a lot but forcing me nevertheless to
spend time and money away from the
campaign Trail in order to fight bogus
made up accusations and charges that's
what they're doing I'm sorry I won't be
able to go to Iowa today I won't be able
to go to New Hampshire today because I'm
sitting in a courtroom on
because his attorney general
charged me with something
terribly
[Applause]
there he is looking around smiling thank
you thank you very much for that chain
of bull s-h-i-t bull s-h-i-t
but you know what's not the
great sleep that you can get with Helix
right now go to Helix sleep.com with
everything going on in the world right
now you could really use a good night's
sleep that is why you need to check out
Helix mattress Helix is harnessed years
of extensive mattress expertise to bring
their customers a truly elevated sleep
experience they just launched their new
Helix Elite the Helix Elite collection
includes six different mattress models
each tailored for specific sleep
positions and firmness preferences I've
had my Helix for years now I love it
night after night I sleep like a sweet
baby and I want you to do the same Helix
has a sleep quiz that matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress because why would you
buy a mattress that was made for someone
else get out of my mattress I'm a
married man man go to helixsleep.com
Knowles take their two minute sleep quiz
find the perfect mattress for your body
and sleep type their flexible payment
plans make it so that a great night's
sleep is never far away Helix is
offering 20 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners hurry
over to helixsleep.com Knowles with
Helix better sleep starts right
now
you know me I don't
I don't like to use blue language I
don't like to go Blue okay naughty
language I like this is a family show I
try to keep it try to keep it a little
elevated
I don't like it when my politicians and
Statesmen use naughty language but
for it every now and again
there's a rhetorical use for that kind
of language
if there ever were a use for that kind
of language this would be it
because
Joe Biden is behaving in a way that is
so egregious that is such a violation of
standards and Norms of the American
political order
that it
has called for a response in kind
this this isn't not the kind of thing
that that suggests that we ought to play
by the Marquess of Queensbury rules
Joe Biden is Prosecuting his chief rival
the political opposition this is total
Banana Republic stuff it's over nothing
it is over BS and Trump is calling that
out and this is
the core of the Trump campaign
and this is what I think is is driving
Trump's primary opponents a little bit
crazy especially Ron DeSantis because
he's the number two guy
the DeSantis supporters are saying dos
Santos is better at wielding power
DeSantis has a more conservative record
DeSantis has a more coherent political
Vision DeSantis has more discipline
rhetorically and politically DeSantis
hires better people DeSantis does this
this is not going to weigh in on the
Merit of those claims but let's say
they're all true
sure
but Trump is a wrench in the system
Trump is is a rejection of the whole
system
DeSantis right now as his campaign is
being run represents maybe the sleekest
fastest cleanest most efficient way to
play Within the system Trump the way his
campaign is being run represents a
rejection of the system
that's the difference that's why his
supporters in that room were chanting BS
bull s-h-i-t bull s-h-i-t and there's
Trump there and he's kind of smiling
goes yep thank you thank you that's what
it is
it's not well when you really think
about it Trump probably shouldn't have
he shouldn't have given that speech that
day on January 6th and when you actually
when you look at the U.S code you know
he wasn't supposed to have that
particular document and even though
other presidents have done it his was it
was his was form 37258 instead of which
you're not really supposed to have
instead of this it's like shut up no
it's BS it's a Banana Republic political
prosecution this is Joe Biden a crook
throwing his chief rival his chief
political threat in the can like they do
in dictatorships and silly illegitimate
countries around the world
and so the response to that is not well
actually look at this special legal
argument the answer to that is this is
BS and you know I got two words for you
that aren't happy birthday liberal
establishment that's the answer that's
why the Trump campaign continues to be
strong and continues to grow and this is
why Trump says I'm one indictment away
from winning the election
and so if if any other campaign wants to
compete with that
I think they're going to have to get a
little bit clearer in their rejection of
this obviously BS system
when and it's maybe an impossible spot
because Trump kind of has that market
cornered so if you're going to run
against Trump you have to you have to
run against the claims that Trump is
making and if you run against the claims
that Trump is making you are necessarily
going to be more inclined to legitimize
the political order so it might just be
an impossible situation even for the
greatest politician in the world but
that is why people are drawn to the
campaign
Trump keeps making this point he keeps
going back this is what's driving a lot
of more establishment type Republicans
and even some non-establishment
Republicans crazy is
Trump keeps going back to relitigate
2020 which a lot of people are saying we
don't want to hear about 2020 we want to
hear about 2024. Trump keeps returning
to this theme
only a party that cheats that elections
would make it illegal to question those
elections it's the only ones that would
really make it
difficult
if you can challenge a rigged election
think of it we're not looking to do it
we want you know they don't go after the
people that rigged the election they go
after the people that want to find out
what the hell happened it's a disgrace
it's a disgrace now the Geniuses the
total Geniuses in the GOP Consulting and
chattering class they say that any
Republican nominee especially Trump if
he wants to win in 2024 it needs to move
on
from issues like election Integrity has
to move on stop talking about the last
election oh quit going that doesn't pull
well in the suburbs they tell us I don't
know
that is not going to happen
that is not going especially if the
nominee is Trump especially if Trump
continues to dominate the polls that is
not going to happen
because the chief reason to vote for
Trump
is that you think that things are so bad
that we need a rejection of the system
the chief reason to vote for Trump is
because it is not because you have this
particular view on immigration or that
particular view this particular view on
trade or that particular view it's
because you think that the system is so
corrupt that you can't even trust the
Integrity of the elections the reason to
vote for Trump is that they rigged it in
2020. that's one of the main reasons to
do it the reason to vote for Trump in
2016 is because the Republicans and
Democrats have been working together as
a unit party to advance the same
unpopular and wrong-headed policies on
trade on immigration and on foreign
policy no matter which party got into
Power didn't matter which party got into
Power you always had a lot more
immigrants you always had a lot more
Foreign Wars you always had a lot more
Outsourcing of jobs and materials and
Manufacturing and a lot more neglect of
America's Heartland the Forgotten men
and women the deplorables the
irredeemables and so it was a rigged
game and Trump came in and he said it's
a rigged game and I'm not going to play
by it it's the same thing here with a
particular focus on Election integrity
if you don't think that if you think
that Trump's just a sore loser and
things aren't really that bad and we're
all being hyperbolic then you're not
going to vote for Trump
you're probably going to vote for
DeSantis maybe you're going to vote for
Vivek
maybe I don't know maybe if you're
if you really want to return to the
mid-2000s you'll vote for one of the
other candidates
but if you are inclined to vote for
Trump
you particularly want to talk about 2020
and election integrity and if that is
going to lose you the general maybe
that's the tragedy of it I know maybe
that will lose the general maybe that's
that doesn't resonate with voters
but there's no incentive for Trump to
stop talking about that that is the
raison debt of his campaign
now
when I want to make myself feel a little
bit better
what do I do I remember that politics
was always a little bit crazy I try to
calm down maybe I go for a walk and I
sit down for a nice delicious plate of
good ranchers right now go to
goodranches.com use promo code Knowles I
don't know about you but this summer
heat in Nashville feels hotter than it's
been in years thanks to inflation we're
feeling the heat in more ways than one
am I right the one thing that I'm not
sweating this summer though is my meat
price thanks to good ranchers good
ranchers has this insane program where
they lock in your price of meat for two
years which is crazy it's an it's an
amazing deal you should sign up for it
right now I don't know how they're doing
it good ranchers also has just the best
quality meat out there it's so freaking
good I eat it multiple times a week I
love the steaks they've turned me into a
rib eye guy they now have pork very
excited for the bratwurst bundle uh the
burgers are the best I've ever had
they're just it's just an amazing
product at a ridiculously low price and
you can lock in that low price I don't
think I need to say anymore go to
goodranchers.com right now use code
Knowles can w-les you get 30 bucks off
any box this is 100 American Meat
extremely high quality you're saving a
ton of money goodranches.com promo code
Knowles goodranchors.com American Meat
delivered are you planning to send your
kids off to college this year
condolences now I've been on campuses uh
for a long time I travel to many of them
every single year and I've done it for
many years I've seen firsthand how
liberal ideology has infiltrated and
polluted these once great universities
give your kids a Fighting Chance by
sending them off with Jeremy's razors
right now
get up to 20 off select razor and men's
care bundles such as shampoo body wash
and conditioner all paraben free
sulfate-free woke free and made in the
USA get your boy a Precision five razor
with welded steel blades and flip-backed
trimmer that will groom his face not his
world view help your son Escape
academia's leftist indoctrination by
more than just a close shave go to
jeremiseracers.com for major deals and
give Jeremy's back to college bundles a
full ride today
this is all too much for some
Republicans
the the focus on Election Integrity the
insistence that we we defend a guy who's
under multiple indictments for all
manner of evil that Joe Biden is
flinging at him this is too much even
for some people who have long been
considered conservative Republicans
judge ludig is
a pretty big figure
on the right
in the Judiciary he's been a big feeder
for conservative Supreme Court Justices
for clerks he's been he's been a major
figure even if you haven't heard of him
he's had a big influence on the right
he's just come out
on CNN
and he said there there's basically no
Republican party anymore
do you think he is still a clear and
present danger to American democracy I
do poppy uh uh more so today than he was
uh uh last summer when I testified
before the Congress of the United States
the trials of the former president now
will become uh together with the events
of January 6. uh the singular Infamous
events uh in American history just to
remind our viewers you are a
conservatives conservative Trump is
winning by a mile in the polls
Republican officials are lining up
behind him
what do you think has happened to your
party I I'm not a political person Poppy
and uh
frankly I don't care about the
Republican party at all except to the
extent that the the two political
parties in in America are the political
guardians of democracy today
in my view there is no Republican party
to counter the Democratic party uh in
the country and for that reason uh
American democracy is in grave Peril
there it is
Trump drove judge ludig as he's driven
many people completely insane
completely insane and so CNN does this
thing that they often do since now
listen we just want to be clear for our
viewers you're a conservatives
conservative
and usually when the liberal media say
this it's not true usually they're
saying it to Liz Cheney or Adam
kinzinger or Jeff Flake or some big
squishy lib who's practically a Democrat
who occasionally votes to cut taxes and
they say well you're a you're a true
conservatives conservative that's almost
never true in the case of ludig
it's almost true
I don't want to downplay
the the role that judge ludic has played
in on the right
he he has been considered one of the
more conservative figures in the country
over the past
number of decades now
but he is not today
the conservatives conservative obviously
spends all his time whining about Donald
Trump you heard what he said right there
he said I don't care about the
Republican Party
that tells you a lot that tells you a
lot about
the the shallow
weakened type of conservatism that is
predominated over the last 20 30 years
since I don't care about the Republican
Party
I just I just want there to be two
strong parties
I want there to be two strong parties in
America and we just kind of duke it out
a little bit but we basically maintain
the status quo that's the implication
I don't want to win substantive
victories necessarily as much as I want
to maintain certain procedural Norms
procedural Norms that have redounded to
the benefit of the libs for the past 70
years
this is
the kind of the distinction you hear
between
conservative jurists and say
originalist or textualist jurists
there's a lot to recommend originalism
and textualism but it's a distinction
here because originalism is concerned
with a a procedural Norm a certain
interpretive principle not with
substantive Goods the these judicial
philosophies that have predominated on
the right for the past 50 years or so
have stated we don't really care what
the substantive end is we're not
necessarily referring we're not focusing
on the background principles of justice
that undergird our legal system we're
just focusing on exactly what the
positive
text of the statute was understood to
mean at the time of its passing
which is fine and tactically sometimes
that can redown to our benefit
but it's kind of weak sauce
and the conservative movement today is
much less concerned with maintaining the
precise procedural Norms of 1972 and
we're much more concerned with
substantive Goods we're much less
concerned with defending I don't know
free speech in the abstract than we are
with
defining what the inevitable standards
and constraints of our speech will be
what the what what we want to say this
is the point I made in my book
speechless which is that where's that
Bell thanks guys there we go which is
that free speech in the abstract doesn't
mean anything to people who have nothing
to say
I'm not a conservative because I want to
maintain the exact status quo and just
have a lot of fun debate in the
allegedly free Marketplace of ideas
I want a good Society
I want a good normal sane place to be
where I can be free and the true sense
of freedom in that that I can flourish
not just become enslaved to my appetites
and to the predations of bad people who
are who are doing bad things
that's a big shift
and conservatives who really came of age
in I don't know the 90s early 2000s they
don't like they don't like all this talk
about good and bad and true and false
and beautiful and ugly they don't like
that kind of talk but that's where we're
at and and so we're going to lose people
who
who are not ready for that fight
speaking of politicians of a certain age
Dianne Feinstein has been hospitalized
she is the Democrat senator
she's quite aged she's a woman of a
certain age she is a 90 I think now she
had shingles earlier this year all sorts
of health problems that came from that
she's in a wheelchair she seems to have
some cognitive issues she had a fall she
was briefly hospitalized she then
returned home and people are calling on
her to step down Democrats are calling
on her to step down and oddly enough
Republicans seem even more focused on
making her step down
and I just don't see why
I don't see a single good reason
why we should call on Dianne Feinstein
to step down
I see why Democrats want her to step
down they want her to step down because
there's a Democrat Governor in
California and he can appoint some
very young robust far leftist Senator to
replace Dianne Feinstein who by the
standards of the democratic party is
relatively moderate today I get why they
want her to why do we want her to
because she's old
she we don't need all these old people
anymore
come on it's embarrassing how old she is
let's go get her out of here
that's it
that's the that is that is the degree of
strategic and tactical sophistication on
the right I'm sorry to say for a lot of
the establishment Republicans
what good is done by replacing her right
now
nothing
what bad is done you get a younger more
energetic more radical Senator who's
doing more stuff so why would we do that
well because just don't you think we
shouldn't have old people first of all
the Senate comes from the word Senex
which means old old man so I don't have
a problem with old people maybe she's a
little over the hill and should retire
but okay we've got to
cut it we conservatives need to cut it
with the rosy idealistic nonsense
about politics and start seeing power a
little more clearly I'm not saying we
behave in a way that's immoral or a way
that's unjust I would never encourage
that but we need to stop
engaging in politics as though we're
living in 1952 and nothing has changed
and we're all just dealing in good faith
and the Democrats aren't Prosecuting the
political opposition leader in the
country no they would never do such a
thing come on let's just all come
together we kind of we basically agree
in the end don't we no we don't man
they're trying to imprison the former
president the leader of the opposition
they're trying to they're spying on
Catholics they're lying about spying on
Catholics just for going to mass they're
they're calling parents domestic
terrorists they're trying to imprison
pro-life advocates for protesting
infanticide they're giving awards to the
infanticidal maniacs and they're they're
trying to throw the pro-life advocates
in prison for 10 years 11 years we're
not we're not in 1952 anymore guys
the procedural Norms are gone the only
people who are playing by the old
procedural Norms are they're
conservatives
and we're going to be playing by them
all the way to the gulags
no reason I'm endorsing Dianne Feinstein
for three more terms speaking of power
shifting gears a little bit here Olivia
Newton-John you know the actress Olivia
Newton John
she died a little while ago and her
family has been describing paranormal
experiences of seeing her after her
death
and I bring up this story because a lot
of people have these kinds of stories
they'll say oh my mother died and you
know I saw
a little something out of the glint of
my eye and I or I saw this odd little
sign and I knew that was I knew that
birdie was my mother or I knew that
weird image that I saw that was my
mother I felt my mother around me and
that's what they were describing
they're saying two weeks after she
passed my phone accidentally took a
picture of my dog
and they're floating by his head with a
little blue orb the same color as this
and this is a
uh
Olivia Newton-John's daughter saying
this mom and I had talked years back
we'd watch these paranormal shows
and I'd say you got to show up for me
and she was like I'll show up as one of
those orb things
what do you know the phone goes off and
look there's a little orb see that's
that's Mommy
I don't mean to
drag anybody for grieving grief is very
hard thing to do
a lot of people think this is harmless
this kind of fantasy a lot of a lot of
people think it's comforting oh who
cares I don't think that's I don't think
the orb is Olivia Newton-John
and a lot of people say oh it's it's
it's comforting to think that maybe you
know your mother's there
I don't think it is comforting
and as our culture has lost religion
we've we've become much more
superstitious you see this in a lot of
the most prominent ideologies these days
some of which I'm not allowed to talk
about on YouTube but you know which ones
I'm talking about a lot of bizarre
superstitions that we're engaging in
today about the nature of the Soul all
sorts of weird stuff new Agee kind of
stuff
it's not comforting though
what is comforting is systematic
theology
it is I know it doesn't sound comforting
it sounds kind of cold and clinical but
it is I know a lot of people want to say
I'm spiritual I'm not religious I don't
believe in organized religion I don't
believe in dogmas I don't believe in all
that rigidity that's all man-made that's
not I believe in spirit man you know
spirituality is not comforting religion
can be comforting
it is comforting in that it gives you
strength sometimes the little little um
disruptive of what you're doing if they
tell you if your religion tells you
you're on the wrong track that can be
distressing but it'll get you back on
the right track but the reason that the
orb stuff the new AEG spirituality is
not comforting is because it raises more
questions than it answers if my mother
is a little blue orb what the hell does
that mean about the soul what does that
mean what happens after we die we all
just float around as little orbs is she
conscious is she in heaven is she in
hell is she in another dimension or I
guess she's in this Dimension are there
just ghosts everywhere
is there God
is there Justice
what does that mean
I I have a view of what happens
which is that when you die you go to
heaven or hell
and you might need a period of
expregation you know if you're not in a
perfect state to enter into heaven but
that's it that's what happens and then
there will be a final judgment and a
resurrection of the dead and a new
Heaven and a new Earth that's that's
what I believe that's a Christian view
that's what Christians believe we say
this this kind of thing in the Creed
I believe there's a cloud of witnesses
of saints
I I believe this is expressed in the the
book of the Apocalypse where the Saints
are praying for us they've got little
little baskets which is which has
incense coming out of it which you see
reflected in the mass and that the the
incense in the buckets it's the prayers
of the saints that they're praying for
us and that God loves us and wants us to
be with him and I believe all that so
when there are little coincidences you
know if you're grieving and a little you
see a little birdie fly out the window
or you see a little orb and you say look
at that I don't think that's my mother I
don't think that's the my dearly
departed person but I do think well
there's a providential order to the
universe things make sense there is
ultimately Justice and that is
comforting but it's comforting because
the rigor of logic has been applied to
spiritual intuitions that is what
theology is theology is Faith seeking
understanding
spirituality is just BS that you try
superstitious nonsense that you try to
tell yourself to comfort yourself but
SCS Lewis points out if you look for
truth you might find comfort in the end
if you look for Comfort you'll find
neither truth nor Comfort only soft soap
and Wishful Thinking to begin and in the
end despair now when you're seeking
understanding you ought to check out
Hillsdale College right now go to
hillsdale.edu Knowles are you a few
years or maybe decades out of school and
wondering what the heck did I even learn
and what was the point you might think
to yourself that you don't have the time
to learn something new well if that's
you then know that you're not alone and
it's not too late since 1844 Hillsdale
College has been providing education and
Faith freedom and character they've
taken some of the core classes they
teach on campus made them available for
free online to anyone who wants to learn
that's right for free there are 39 free
courses to choose from ranging from the
US Constitution the Book of Genesis to
free market economics they're easy to
follow and they're self-paced so you can
start whenever you want in fact you can
start right now it's everything you need
all in one place with no long-term
commitment let Hillsdale College be your
guide learn when and where you want
Hillsdale is absolutely terrific loved
visiting and you can bring that right
now to your home through your computer
and through your phone go to
hillsdale.edu Knowles to enroll no cost
it's easy to get started hillsdale.edu
Knowles to register hillsdale.edu
Knowles
my favorite comment yesterday is from
Erica HL my favorite transition by far
she says is Michael talking about diet
pills then moving immediately to a clip
of Chris Christie that's not nice
that's not nice why would you shouldn't
say that who would do that
it's not nice at all I do not I don't
endorse that okay speaking of
Supernatural things
some new alien nonsense just dropped so
it's our weekly alien distraction here
we go the new alien nonsense some comes
from some scientist who claims that he
has proof possibly of alien life this
object was moving very fast faster than
95 percent of the Stars near the sun and
it also had material strength tougher
than all the Rocks we had seen over the
past decade in the NASA catalog so there
is a chance I I wouldn't quantify it I
would just say it's quite possible that
it's different than a rock and what we
are doing now is analyzing the
composition of the molten droplets that
fell off this object when it was exposed
to the fireball that it created as it
moved through the air and we are getting
some interesting results but I cannot
detail them until we've put them
together in a paper scientific paper
that we hope to make publicly available
to everyone it would mean that we have a
neighbor that we are not alone just like
realizing that you know when you go out
to your backyard and you find a tennis
ball that was thrown by neighbor you
realize yes I do have a neighbor that's
the basic change to our perspective
about our place in the universe and it
will inspire us to explore space it may
make us better instead of fighting with
each other perhaps will it will be a
wake-up call for us to realize that
there are more important things in life
than fighting with other people
there it is
there is my evidence
that this is BS well there's a lot of
evidence in this BS
but this is my this is the tell for me
so first it's the usual story oh I've
got all this great evidence I can't tell
you about it
yeah but I got man this is some really
great strong evidence we are not alone
we have neighbors it's so clear yeah I
don't have a paper yet or anything but
just take my word for it well I'm gonna
do a paper in the future and then I hope
I can make it publicly available but
anyway before I do any of that I just
want to go on TV and I want to let you
know there are totally aliens totally
and my proof is you should take my word
for it okay this is it's always the same
old story oh yeah we've I found a thing
actually my friend's cousin's brother
found a rock in his yard and we know
somehow that it means that there's ET
out there and so but and he told me I
wish he could be here right now he could
tell you himself but it's just me so
anyway take my word for it
and don't pay any attention to uh the
imprisonment of the uh opposition leader
in the U.S
don't pay any attention to your churches
being inspired on don't pay any
attention to the prospect of World War
III in Ukraine don't pay any attention
to the haphazard economy that we've got
under Biden don't pay any attention to
the millions of foreigners crossing your
borders no no there's there's I'm
promising you man there's stuff in outer
space
that would complicate if not undermine
your entire traditional cosmology and
your place in the universe but the tell
okay that's all the preface to say the
tell to me that this is a psyop is
he says there at the end he goes well
you know what this would mean
is that look we don't occupy the place
that we think we occupy in the universe
now we traditionally think that we
occupy the center of the universe that
the universe is basically made for us
that there are non-rational creatures
and there is God you know and pure
spirit and that we're right there right
in the middle of it we're the meaning of
those two things and the world was made
for us and we're stewards of that world
we're made in the image and likeness of
God and he's saying yeah this is we're
going to disrupt all that
and maybe then we'll stop fighting with
each other
and then maybe we'll just come together
and then maybe we'll just all cooperate
all the time and maybe oh okay so now
after all the BS here my cousin's
brother's friend totally has proof of
aliens you get to the point of it which
is a political point
we're going to change our political
order
we're going to stop fighting we're gonna
have to cooperate we got these we're
going to unite because we got this this
alien invader
and we're going to stop we're going to
have some political changes which
something tells me is what this whole
UFO nonsense has been about from the
very beginning
speaking of things that aren't real
Wayne Brady is a pansexual
what's a pansexual I don't know it's
kind of funny that he opens his video in
which he expresses his pansexuality in
the kitchen
so there's no pants though he's washing
a dish
[Music]
[Applause]
he's a great performer
[Music]
there's some guy there some gal there
some rainbow flag dude
I'm Brady with
nice Pink Suit over here
[Music]
okay so that that's his video and he
comes out and says in this post this is
the text of his post he goes as someone
who gets to bring joy to others daily on
TV it's been ironic that I don't
experience it as much as I'd like I
advocate mental health for all
and a part of that is self-transparency
and doing my work I've come to see a few
truths one of them being that I want to
be free to love whomever I want this
truth makes me pan and part of the lgbtq
family scary as hell to say it out loud
but there it is people I admire most are
the ones who are brave enough to be
themselves unapologetically and I'm
going to be happy a real man in my eyes
isn't afraid to be honest and happy I'm
going to be living my best life and then
he tags a bunch of people including his
ex-wife Wayne Brady has been married
twice actually married like to a woman
and has a child
and he's decided now in his middle age
that he's
a pansexual and what is pansexual he
describes it he says pansexual is like
bisexual with an open mind
how do you get more open-minded than
bisexual I think it means that you are
bisexual but you're you're
I actually think that's what I mean I
don't really know but that's what I've
inferred that means
and he says I just I just want to be
happy
he said I advocate mental health role
when when someone prattles on and on and
on about mental health you can know that
this person is in a bad State and is
certainly a liberal because mental
health is the new slogan that is used by
people who are ignoring spiritual health
who have usually maybe they have some
psychological problems but at a deeper
level they almost certainly almost 100
of the time have spiritual problems and
they don't want to acknowledge that
because they're materialists and and so
they they instead say well if I can just
shup something something else then I'll
feel better but of course that won't
happen that will only make the issue
worse and to to bring his wives into
this and to have them pretend to
celebrate this it's very very sad I
don't mean to knock Wayne Brady I think
he's a very talented guy and very very
funny is is one of my favorite uh
performers of the 90s and 2000s but this
is really sad because he's he's
obviously unhappy he's seeking
happiness in this perverted form of
Liberation he thinks that just being
able to do whatever I want to do
whenever I want to do whenever I want
that's that's going to make me happy and
it won't that's the lie that's the lie
not just of radical leftism it's a lie
not just of lgbtism or is that it's the
LIE of liberalism the lie that your
happiness will be in the expression of
your individual sovereignty that's the
lie that Satan tells himself in Milton's
Paradise Lost better to Reign and held
and serve in heaven the mind is its own
place and it can make a hell of Heaven
in heaven and hell but it isn't true
your exercise of your own individual
will and your sovereignty can feel
in mod in modernity we we feel as though
that's the highest good it's not that's
just a means to an end
it's just a it's just a it's just a
procedure it gets to what we're talking
about with judge ludic it's just a
procedure
the question is what what is the
substance that you're aiming at what
choices are you making how are you using
your will
what are you using your will for
what is good
putting the cart before the horse and
now
Wayne Brady is going to be attracted to
all sorts of things men women carts
horses and probably everything in
between today's theology Thursday baby
the rest of the show continues now we
have Rabbi pincos Taylor on to get we've
had a Protestant
we've had a Catholic now we have a Jew
to talk about
all sorts of weird mysterious
esoteric kind of things
like aliens and demons which is what
they really are so become a member right
now use code Knowles to check out for
two months free on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign